estamos aquí en bogotá en el park way
ahora tendría que estar comenzando a las
seis el tercero de los actos organizados
por la alcaldía de bogotá de claudia
lópez que consiste en una velatón y
también en un cacerolazo en memoria de
las trece víctimas que murieron el 9 y
el 10 de septiembre cuando hubo
enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y
policía cabe destacar que en por lo que
se ve en el ambiente parece que tanto
ayer como hoy ha descendido la
intensidad del conflicto y por lo que
vemos aquí en el parc güell en un
céntrico parque ahí como un ambiente más
festivo a un lado hasta la policía
custodiando una de las estaciones de
policía que fueron incendiadas tanto el
miércoles como el jueves y al otro lado
tenemos a gente que está concentrada con
música bailando también los vecinos han
organizado han creado una biblioteca
popular para resignificar este lugar y
darle otro otro significado después de
los hechos violentos que sucedieron por
parte del gobierno también ha habido
reacciones el gobierno ha dicho que en
caso de que se demuestre que hubo un
exceso de fuerza conductora los
manifestantes con él
de armas de fuego habrá que tomar
medidas drásticas sin embargo hay
también parte de la población que
critica esta jornada de perdón y de
reconciliación
primero porque consideran que aún no ha
habido los funerales de las tres
personas fallecidas y por otro lado
también porque consideran que estamos en
un momento en el que el hecho de la
reconciliación no es un buen momento
ahora mismo después de todo lo que ha
sucedido